le 9 mars 1944
une personne bien ennuyé c'était bien
madame marché qui habitait au 22 rue
lesueur à paris dans le 16ème
arrondissement une rue qui prend dans
l'avenue de la grande armée pour aller
jusqu'à l'avenue foch c'est que madame
mars et habiter au cinquième étage et
que ses fenêtres données sur un hôtel
particulier situé de l'autre côté de la
rue au 21 rue lesueur hors de la
cheminée du 21au le sport s'élevait une
épaisse fumée est cette fumée santé
horriblement mauvais alors le premier
jour mal à marcher n'a trop rien dit
elle en a parlé à son mari dont il a
rentré le soir
et puis le deuxième jour ça sentait
toujours aussi mauvais ça fumait
toujours autant puis le 11 mars le
troisième jour elle en laye vraiment
assez quand son mari est entré à 18h30
de son travail et dise on peut pas
supporter ça davantage regarde le vent a
tourné
maintenant le vent rabat la fumée dans
la rue et c'est insoutenable
cette atroce et tous les habitants de la
rue de ce faire tous les voisins étaient
bien de cet avis les gens s'attroupent
est alors monsieur mars et s'est décidé
à aller sonner à la porte de cet hôtel
particulier
c'était une fort belle porte à porte
aille plutôt et je marchais a sonné une
première fois rien deux trois quatre
fois rien personne ne venait
alors seulement il a vu apposer sur le
portail sur l'une des faces du portail
un écriteau délavé d'ailleurs par la
pluie qui indiquait absent pour un mois
s'adressait 18 rue des lombards à
auxerre visiblement il y avait personne
dans cette maison il n'y aurait personne
avant longtemps
alors est ce qu'on supporte ray cette
odeur plus longtemps et est ce qu'on
attendrait éternellement messieurs mars
est rentré chez lui et il a téléphoné à
la police et peu de temps après deux
agents arrivés sur leur vélo
l'agent tessier et l'agent fillion qui
venaient voir ce qui se passait en
trouver l'aller les voisins qui ont dit
mais tu es rendez vous compte santé
alors ils ont sonné aussi personnes et
c'étaient des agents qui connaissaient
leur métier ils sont allés à côté voir
la conscient et l'inconscient jeu leur a
dit ben oui c'est vrai l'hôtel a été
vendue en 1941 par le prince de
colloredo mensuel qui en était le
propriétaire un certain docteur petiot
il habite 66 rue caumartin et j'ai même
son téléphone c'est pigalle 77 11
voilà une concierge bien informés alors
les agents sont allés téléphoner au
docteur pq une voix féminine leur a
répondu au téléphone quand ils ont
appelé pigalle 77 11 à l'eau madame mais
ce que nous sommes chez le docteur
petiot oui monsieur ici la police nous
voudrions parlé au docteur petit et un
instant après c'était une voix masculine
bonjour messieurs que se passe-t-il
alors il raconte la fumée le peut-être
un seul cheminée le danger d'un incendie
très bien est ce que vous êtes entré
dans la maison dit la voix du docteur
petiot très calme
non non puisque c'est fermé très bien
j'arrive avec les clés je serai là dans
un garde et dragons alors les agents à
temps le quart d'heure c'est cool
20 minutes personne c'est pas possible
ça semble plus en plus mauvais
maintenant la nuit est tombée sur la rue
le souhait puis enfin vraiment on ne
peut pas attendre parce que si c'est un
feu de cheminée on ne sait pas où ça ira
et les agents vent téléphoné aux
pompiers
m quelques instants plus tard la sirène
caractéristiques des voitures de
pompiers il arrive on leur explique la
faire il déploie l'échelle monte au
premier étage casse une vitre entre dans
l'hôtel qui est plongé dans la nuit
puisque je répète la nuit est tombée
ce moment en mars la nuit tombe à 7 et
là ils s'éclairent avec leur lampe de
poche leurs torches et il se trouve dans
une pièce où il ya une sorte de
bric-à-brac de mobilier des meubles
entassés les uns sur les autres et une
épaisse couche de poussière alors ils
vont vers la cage d'escalier et c'est là
de la cage de l'escalier puis surgit
l'honneur l'odeur insoutenable encore
bien plus atroces que celles consenties
2 1 et ils vont se guider que sur cette
odeur ils descendent au rez de chaussée
toujours ce bric à brac de mobilier
cette poussière et puis de descendre au
sous-sol là ils sont guidés par le bruit
des chaudières d'une tuerie hier qui
ronfle et débouche dans une petite pièce
où se trouvent nos chaudières une petite
ndre en est là ce qu'ils voient à la
lueur à la fois du brasier puisque la
porte de la chaudière de la plus grande
chaudière est ouverte et donc le feu est
clair tout également ils ont leurs
lampes de poche ce qu'ils voient est
abominable défie toute description par
terre sur le sol un amoncellement de
débris humains
il ya des troncs il ya des crânes il ya
des cuisses il ya des bras il ya un
corps entier coupée dans le sens de la
longueur aux deux parties et puis de la
grande chaudière dont la porte est
entrouverte il ya un bras
alors seulement il remonte et ouvre de
l'intérieur le portail sorte le plus
jeune des trois pompiers vomi sur le
trottoir et le chef des pompiers dit aux
policiers ça vous regarde aller voir
qu'ils y vont une revente ils sont
affolés ils appellent le commissariat et
en attendant des renforts du monte la
garde là à l'entrée du portail
lorsqu'ils vont arriver dans la nuit un
homme sur une bicyclette et cet homme
rentre dans la cour mais où allez vous
disent les agents je suis le frère du
propriétaire
il me suit qu'est ce qui se passe est
bien allé voir lui dise des agents alors
il s'avance il descend vers la cave
ville mais sans mouchoir sur le nez
revient et les agents le regard et ils
les regardent aussi et le redis
dites-moi est-ce que vous êtes de bons
français bien sûr disait deux agents bon
alors en un mot voilà la sphère
résistance nous sommes un réseau qui
avons pris pour tâche d'exécuter les
allemands et leurs collaborateurs
tous ces gens qui sont là ont fait
l'objet d'un procès il ya des dossiers
sur eux ils ont été exécutés alors
maintenant il faut que j'aille prévenir
le réseau il bouge avec détruire les
dossiers vive la france
yves de gaulle répondent les deux agents
filet on n'a rien vu et l'homme s'en va
dans la nuit l'homme qui n'était pas du
tout le frère du propriétaire mais
qu'était docteur pettiaux alors pourquoi
parler de la sphère pétion eh bien
d'abord parce que il reste beaucoup de
problèmes autour de la fermeture et je
suis de ceux avec stefan zweig qui
pensent que le mystère exerce une action
créatrice et puis aussi on côtoie sans
cesse les paroxysmes dans cette affaire
et je suis de ceux qui pensent que c'est
par le paroxysme qu'on peut le mieux
essayer de savoir quelque chose sur les
hommes et puis aussi c'est que nous
sommes à un moment où on se penche sur
une époque c'était pas que c'est
l'occupation et peut-être parce que
justement trente années ont passé nous
sommes plus intéressés plus retenu par
cette époque
et nous sommes bien obligés de nous dire
qu'il n'y aurait sans doute pas eu
d'affaires petit au sens l'occupation de
la france il ya eu pendant quatre ans
une industrie de la mort conduite par
heinrich himmler bien s'il n'y avait pas
eu l'empereur de la mort il n'y aurait
peut-être pas eu l'artisan de la mort
que fut le docteur pétion ça n'est pas
par hasard qu après les souvenirs de
rené les ans des amis de peugeot
après les études de jacques delarue et
d'allemands sont bien coup sur coup
presque ensemble sont parus il ya
quelques mois deux ouvrages celui de
jean marc varaut et celui de rené
tavernier croyez vous que ce soit un
hasard non alors qu'ils étaient ce
docteur petiot
il est né à auxerre en 1897
il est le fils d'un employé des postes
enfants difficiles confié à une nourrice
qui s'appelle henriette détails sur le
petit enfant de trois ans il trempe un
chat dans l'eau bouillante ne se fait
pas tous les jours chez les enfants de 3
ans heureusement
et puis un peu plus tard il étrangle le
chien il est rendu à ses parents
bon élève nommé plusieurs fois aux
distributions les prix et puis ce sont
les classes plus importante le
secondaire hélas cet enfant devient
assez curieux par exemple il nous place
un de ses camarades sur la porte de
l'école dans la cour sur la porte de la
classe c s'amuse au jeu du couteau
envoyé le couteau autour de lui c'est un
jeu sous même un peu particulier et olam
est malade et si tu es tellement
terrorisés qui n'ose pas se dérober une
autre fois le petit peu tu as vol le
revolver ordonnance de son père et tire
un coup de feu vers le plafond de la
place ça aussi ça ne se fait en même pas
tous les jours et puis à mesure qu'il
grandit eh bien il va distribuer des
photos pornographiques ses camarades
alors là aussi ce ne sera pas très bien
vu filer aussi des larcins dans la
classe des petites choses qu'on vole
dans les cartables dans les poches sais
pas qui c'est jusqu'au jour où on
s'aperçoit que le petit petit haut avec
un bâton enduit de glu à voler dans les
boîtes aux lettres
l'état de l'être alors il s'est amusé à
envoyer les lettres des uns aux autres
pour troubler les esprits par exemple
une dame qui écrit à son amant il trouve
très bien d'envoyer la lettre au mari ça
disons que c'est un jeu mais quand il
prend les mandats qu'ils veulent elle
est touchée alors là quand même la
police s'en mêle tribunal pour enfants
on le déclare inconscient mais il est
renvoyé du lycée
il fera ses études seul avec l'appui
d'un oncle professeur de philosophie
il faut croire que ça lui réussit
puisque en 1915 à 18 ans il est
bachelier il déclare qu'il sera médecin
s'inscrit au pcn et trois mois après le
change d'avis il s'engage on est en
pleine guerre il s'engage il devance
l'appel blessés
après plusieurs mâles front dans un
endroit particulièrement exposés blessé
au pied gauche une grenade forte
blessures les sur assez grave
quatre mois de soins d'abord au fond et
ensuite à l'arrière mais en même temps
en même temps constatation par les
médecins d'un état de prostration qui
montre qu'il a été traumatisée fortement
traumatisé il est abattu prostré il ne
parle pas il a les yeux vague de temps
en temps des accès de colère frénétique
expertise psychiatrique les déclarer en
état de démence et ça tout de même je
vous demande de vous en souvenir
il n'y aura pas qu'une expertise il
séjournera dans trois asile d'aliénés il
sera interné dans trois asie et
d'ailleurs quand il sera médecin plus
tard jouera avec ce mot de internés et
sur son papier à lettres mettra interne
et d asphyxie qui a trick mais on ne
verra pas les accents aigus ça deviendra
interne leur expertise psychiatrique en
1919 1920 1922 1923 à chaque fois il est
reconnu dément à ce point qu'il est
d'abord réformer avec une pension
d'invalidité à 40%
ensuite à 100% et le rapport d expertise
dit qu' il est hors d'état
il est irrécupérable il est hors d'état
d'accomplir le moindre travail
intellectuel ou physique et en 23 il
aura son à un viol son invalidité
réduite à 50 ans
or ce personnage irrécupérable se dément
qu'est-ce qu'il fait pendant ces années
là bas il fait ça métier
il passe brillamment en 1921 sa thèse de
docteur en médecine avec la mention très
bien alors on ne comprend plus que
qu'est-ce qui se passe qui trompe qui
est ce que les psychiatres sont des
incapables
ou est-ce qu'un personnage irrécupérable
incapable de tout effort physique ou
intellectuelle est capable de passer
sont docteurs en médecine est la mention
très bien alors voilà un des premiers
problèmes de la fermeture parce que la
sphère peux tu ne commences par moment
de la fermeture la faire plutôt commence
avec la naissance de pépieux alors il va
s'installer puisqu'il est médecin et il
va choisir une petite ville de 4000
habitants est allé sur les rives de
l'yonne
villeneuve sur yonne et cette ville
il va s'y installer dans une maison qui
existe encore ou d'ailleurs m'attendent
y exerce toujours un médecin et il va
avoir un prospectus il va lancer sur la
ville de villeneuve sur yonne un
prospectus assez curieux dix ans le
docteur petiot est jeune il faut
aujourd'hui s'adresser un jeune médecin
pour être sûr que celui ci connaissent
les dernières découvertes de la science
allez chez le docteur faye où les gens
viennent et ils se révèlent que le
docteur petiot est un bon médecin et la
clientèle se fend il devient populaire
parce qu'il parle à ses clients très
bien agréablement il est paternelle pour
les enfants pour les pauvres une demande
pas d'honoraires à ce point que ce
médecin populaire séduisant tous les
témoins insiste sur le fait que c'est un
homme séduisant un homme qui a du charme
à ce point que lorsqu'il ya des
élections conseil municipal il se
présente il est élu conseiller municipal
et un peu plus tard il est maire voilà
une réussite pour un jeune médecin
la meilleure clientèle de la ville maire
de sa ville
pas mal il se marie avec une certaine
georgette qui est charmant et qui est la
fille d'un grand restaurateur de la rue
de bourgogne à paris l enseigne de chez
marius est désormais camper tuyaux ira à
paris il ira chez son beau-père et la
rencontre à des députés rencontrera des
des ministres oui monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le député et la vie à
villeneuve sur yonne continue cette
petite ville vous envoyer quelques
aspects voilà le cabinet du maire où il
a exercé voilà cette petite ville qui
vit à leur petit haut parce que peu
oc loeb dans ton pas et peut-être même
en par le temps un peu trop il y a eu
avant même son mariage l'histoire d'une
petite bonne qui est devenue sa
maîtresse
elle s'appelait louisette elle a disparu
alors les gens disent pourquoi at elle
disparu lors certains disent il l'a
assassiné on ne prête qu'aux riches
c'est peut-être après qu'on a commencé à
parler de cette histoire enfin il paraît
qu'à l'époque on l'a dit mais ça ne
semble pas avoir atteint sa réputation
puisqu'il a été élu mais et puis il ya
des tas de petites choses par exemple on
l'accuse d'avoir fraudé sur l'assistance
médicale gratuite et il y a même
poursuit t il est condamné à de la
prison avec sursis et une forte amende
et puis également il semble qu'il se
soit emparée des fonds de la carte des
étrangers l'a également poursuite amende
de nouveau alors là les requêtes ses
fonctionnements pourquoi at il fait ça
il a une clientèle
il a de l'argent il est bien vu il est
honoré
on parle de lui il est heureux en ménage
et un petit garçon qui est venu
s'appelle gérard il adore ce petit
garçon pourquoi at il été trafiqués pour
gagner quelques milliers de francs alors
il est révoqué mais alors le conseil
municipal fait bloc autour de lui refuse
d'administrer la commune et on révoque
si j'ose dire la révocation il redevient
mai et même il se présente au conseil
général et il est élu au conseil d'une
heure alors c'est cette époque qui est
même encore quelque chose d'assez
curieux ya une laiterie qui flambent et
quand on entre après l'incendié dans les
décombres on trouve le cadavre de la les
tirs madame de beaufs et on s'aperçoit
qu'elle a été assommé par un coup qui
lui a défoncé le crâne
alors on l'assassiné on a brûlé la
laiterie après pour maquiller le crime
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est alors
qu'un certain phrase qu un cabaretier
commence à dire en secret à quelques
personnes j'ai vu le docteur petiot
entrer dans la laiterie peu de temps
avant la sortie se fera squatteurs tout
moment on peut le penser
parce que à quelques jours de la petite
houle rencontre voit qu'il boite qu'est
ce qui en fera ce que vous boîte et abat
docteur c'est un rhumatisme pas venez
venez dans mon cabinet je vais vous
faire une piqûre
il y va pq fera ce qu'on rentre chez lui
malaise il est mort une heure après
alors un petit aux médecins l'état civil
délivrera le permis d'inhumer peut-être
sont-ce des coïncidences
mais enfin tout de même on est bien
obligé de voir qu'ils il s'est produit
quelque chose et par exemple quand il
vole de l'électricité stupidement une
branche son câble électrique sur les les
câbles de la ville sans passer par le
conteur quoi ça rime pour gagner quoi
bien entendu on s'en aperçoit pour
ensuite de nouer cette fois c'est la
révocation définitive il est exclu du
concessionnaire pourquoi tout ça semble
qu'il y ait quelque chose d'un petit os
1 un démo vous savez c'est la formule la
vieille formule 1 des membres
ça dit bien ce que ça veut dire alors le
voilà paris quand on veut se perdre
après compte quand on a eu des histoires
on se fond dans la grande ville et
s'installe 66 rue caumartin
et là il lance un prospectus auprès
duquel le petit prospectus de villeneuve
sur yonne d'école jeu d'enfant et ce
prospectus j'aimerais bien que vous le
regardez avec moi regardez le et je
voudrais que vous preniez connaissance
avec moi de quelques formules alors vous
êtes priés de noter que le cabinet
médical tenus précédemment par le député
le réputé docteur valérie 6 au premier
étage du 66 rue caumartin sera tenu
désormais par le docteur marcel petiot
diplômé de la faculté de paris en 1921
conseiller général de l'yonne
il n'y est plus ex internes des hôpitaux
et asie nous savons ce que ça veut dire
médecin de l'office médical permanent de
la scène ça n'existe pas alors ce
cabinet médical en plein paris vous
offre toute facilité d'accès autobus
métro comme martin saint lazare il
comprend matériels les plus modernes
leur leur énumération d'appareils
fantastique alors le docteur petiot
déclare qu'il préside aux accouchement
sans douleur il supprime également la
douleur dans les cas de cancer
ulcérations onan et frites ou encore des
cancers
le
leur petit os promet aussi des résultats
probants dans le traitement des
infections respiratoires et surtout
tuberculeuse dans les maladies
infectieuses du sang blennorragie
syphilis dans les maladies organiques
vous qui par suite de l'art ou de la
fatigue nerveuse avait perdu la force
vitale de la jeunesse vous qui cherchait
à supprimer vos soucis en absorbant des
drogues qui voulaient en perdre
l'habitude vous future maman qui désirez
vous éviter les douleurs de la
parturition vous qui cherchez un remède
introuvable adressez-vous un praticien
qui grâce à ses travaux et à son
expérience pourra vous venir en aide
il est évident que s'il avait existé un
ordre des médecins
en 1936 et bien le docteur petiot
n'aurait pas pu exercer en lançant une
publicité aussi éhontée et aussi
fallacieux et pourtant comme à
villeneuve sur yonne ça va marcher la
clientèle vient ça marche très très bien
les bonnes choses il est paternelle pour
les enfants il se courra pour les
malheureux c'est très bien et puis de
bouche à oreille
les gens viennent et il y as maté l'a
rapidement une très forte clientèle
alors comme il a de l'argent et bien il
va acheter des immeubles s'être un
immeuble à paris rue de reuilly
l'achètera un immeuble à auxerre un
autre à courson les carrières où habite
un de ses amis nay rosen tout va très
bien pour lui le petit grande île est
heureux ils vont au cinéma en famille il
adore les romans policiers il va à
l'hôtel drouot acheter des objets de
collection
et puis en 36 finalement peu de mois
après son arrivée il est devant la
librairie gibert boulevard saint michel
il feuillette un livre de médecine qui
vaut 25 francs il le met dans sa poche
il semble toujours le démon alors le
vendeur le wac court après lui le ramène
police il déclare qu'il va indemniser la
maison gibert menacés chez gibert parce
qu'on ait volé tous les jours on veut
faire un exemple ça tombe sur lui police
tribunal et alors là il change de
système de défense
monsieur le président je suis fou et je
le prouve ice or ces certificats
dressant
expertise et il est déclaré dément alors
là tout de même un expert de plus deux
experts de plus trois experts il est
maintenue interne est obligatoire
puisqu'il ne veut pas saint-ernel lui
même volontairement
il reste sept mois interné et ce n'est
qu'au bout de sept mois alors que le
deuxième rapport d'expertisé a dit qu'il
était dangereux dangereux pour lui-même
dangereux pour autrui
le dernier rapport au bout de sept mois
déclare qu il a l'air d'aller bien que
l'on peut le remettre en circulation
alors la rade encore un problème
voilà un homme qui régulièrement et
constater en état de démence et on lui
permet d'exercer une fonction médicale
où il a la vie des gens entre les mains
eh oui c'est comme ça alors voilà la
guerre
l'armistice l'occupation on en voit le
petit garçon auxerre o bonnaire pour
qu'il mange mieux est petit on reprend
sa cliente
et puis en 1941 il achète ce fameux
hôtel pour placer son argent toujours il
en a beaucoup
ils en gagnent beaucoup ils achètent ce
fameux hôtel particulier de la rue le
seul essai de l'achat de cet hôtel que
la vie de petit os la tournée
alors maintenant il faut citer quelques
noms un nom d'abord jean pierre fin de
bever un drogué sorte de vagabonde
vagabond spécial fait ce qu'il ne vit
qu'avec des prostituées et justement la
femme qui partage sa vie jeanne gaulle
se drogue et elle va chez petit os pour
chercher des ordonnances pour se faire
donner de la drogue
oui parce que petiau avortent facilement
et petit haut fourni facilement les
ordonnances pour de la drogue bien sûr
il y a un alibi puisqu'il dit que c'est
pour soigner des drogués mais il donne
des ordonnances il a donnée justement
qui ne veut pas trop en donner à jean de
gaulle il a donné deux ordonnances afin
des verts qui ne se drogue pas lui et
tout à coup la police découvre on arrête
la fille dort on arrête van bever et
tout de suite il dénonce docteur petiot
et vendent verdi moi je ne suis pas un
drogué donc ce sont des ordonnances de
complaisance cadenet pettiaux pour la
figue aurait pu dire que c'est pour
qu'elle suive une cure de désert de
désintoxication pardon mais pour vendre
des verts puisqu'il n'est pas toxique et
qu'on lui a donnée herbe des ordonnances
la faute est patente radiation certaine
laure plutôt essaye de convaincre van
bever n'y parvient pas et un matin car
fondée vers est libéré matin il est dans
son hôtel lorsque avec un camarade qui
témoignera qu'un homme est arrivé à
appeler van den berghe fans des verts
l'a suivi en disant à son camarade je
n'irai pas au chantier il est livreur de
charbon à ce moment là je n'irai pas au
chantier tu n'as qu'à dire que je suis
malade mais j'irai demain et on ne
reverra jamais vente des verres de sorte
qu'au procès car il y aura procès petit
os pourra dire se vendent des verts qui
m'accusent n'est même pas venus au
procès et ça fera beaucoup d'effet sur
les jus que tout sera condamné quand
même à un an de prison avec sursis et à
10000 fois maman même époque à peu près
une certaine raymonde baudet se drogue
elle obtient des ordonnances de petit au
même jeu il fait des ordonnances pour la
mère de raymond beaudet madame cahit
même jeu police et peut tout qui veut
convaincre madame caïd de dire qu'elle
s'est drogué pour la même raison parce
qu'il ne veut pas qu'on le condamne pour
ordonnances de complaisance
madame caïd tu es convaincu l du bon
docteur je dirais comme ça et puis
ensuite son mari lui dit mais tu es
folle un médecin de famille vient nous y
sommes enfin il ne faut pas faut pas
entrer dans ce jeu ce médecin que vous a
conseillé de ça est un médecin marron un
homme cahit renonce non elle ne dira pas
que les drogués mais comme elle est
loyal il est 7 heures du soir et le gars
son mari je vais annoncer à petit ou que
je ne ferais pas ce qu'il m'a demandé de
faire je serais rentré pour le dîner
dans une heure elle n'est pas là à
l'heure du dîner
elle n'est pas là lendemain on ne
reverra jamais madame caïds comme on n'a
jamais revu jean-pierre vendait
et puis il y as parmi les voisins de
petits os un fourreur a nommé gauche
enough il est juif très inquiet 42 c'est
un moment où les grandes persécution son
entreprise il se confie à petit au
qu'est-ce que je peux faire est petit on
lui dit mais vous n'avez qu'à passer en
amérique du sud
mais comment passerait devant l'amérique
du sud
et moi j'ai une filière vous n'avez qu'à
réaliser tous vos biens vous mettez tout
ça dans une valise et vous venez avec ma
femme non pas avec votre faim elles vont
rejoindre à plus d'un mais comment à la
seule mais attention apportée 25000
francs pour le passage et puis quand
vous serez but à noël vous faudra
beaucoup d'argent alors réalisé tous et
un soir de 1942
madame bouche enough conduit son mari
jusqu'à la rue pergolèse c'est là
qu'elle va lui dire adieu il porte sa
valise la rue tableau les est à deux pas
de la rue de suède et on ne reverra
jamais
le docteur brin de berger le fourreur
goshin jeudi bromberger parce que la
même histoire va se reproduit presque au
même moment
dr brent berger médecin juif lui aussi
est effrayée même proposition de la part
de tuyaux le docteur bruno bergès
disparaît près du métro étoiles on le
reverra jamais et peu de temps avant
cette époque peut tout à fait faire des
travaux dans l'hôtel de la rue lesueur
il a fait aménager son cabinet de
travail un cabinet de consultation
pourquoi dans cet hôtel où il n'y a que
du bric à brac eh bien oui parce qu'il
doit recevoir des gens pourquoi
puisqu'il a un autre cabinet de
consultation il n'explique pas et il
fait aménager un cabinet de consultation
et puis quand on sort de ce cabinet de
consultation il y un couloir et au bout
de ce couloir il y un débarras débarras
très curieusement triangulaire alors il
a fait venir des ouvriers a demandé que
l'on bourg les murs de mâchefers parce
que dit il il va mettre l'appareil de
radiothérapie et il ne faut pas que les
régions puissent traverser le mur mais
qui dit rayons dit aussi sont ces murs
deviennent un sauna et puis au fond du
débarras il fait apposer une double
porte
mais derrière la porte il n'y a rien il
ya le mur et si on voulait ouvrir cette
porte on ne pourrait pas et même si on
arrache et des portes on trouverait le
mur elle elle débouche sur rien cette
double porte pourquoi et puis quand à la
porte qui donne sur le couloir il fait
enlever la poignée intérieure de sorte
que quelqu'un qui rentre dans ce débat
rats croit pouvoir en sortir quand il
veut attends un moment veulent ouvrir la
grande porte et parvient par puisqu'elle
est fausse veut retourner par la porte
par laquelle il est entré voit qu'il
n'ya pas de poignées et puis dans le mur
de ce débat radio a aménagé un viseur il
peut à tout instant voir ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur du départ ce viseur on en
a beaucoup parlé et ce viseur j'ai le
privilège de pouvoir vous le montre
puisque la préfecture de police a eu
l'amabilité de me le prêter pour cette
émission
alors voyez vous cette et par ce côté le
côté le plus important celui ci que on
pouvait regarder que peux-tu au par
conséquent regarder et toute la pièce
lui apparaissait d'un seul coup par un
système de prismes
alors je regarde avec vous je regarde ce
visage je me dis qu'il est bien dommage
que les choses ne parle pas parce que
qu'est ce qu'on a pu voir dans ce viseur
imaginer que des images ce soit après
nié dans son viseur quelle image
terrible
pourtant nous ne savons pas lesquelles
parce que nous n'avons pas su nous ne
serons jamais ce qui s'est passé rue
lesueur nous savons que des hommes des
femmes arrivent le suaire savons qu'on
les revoit plus jamais mais plutôt lui a
une explication il dit comment mais j'ai
fait passer l'ennui c'est que ces gens
ne se révèleront jamais s'ils sont
passés le donnerons bien un jour de leur
nouvelle après la guerre par exemple ya
trente ans de sa non n'a jamais revu
madame caïd depuis 30 ans le docteur
bruce banner j'ai depuis 30 ans
personnes enlevées mais alors il semble
que jusque là le docteur pétillon et
travailler en amateur et qu'il est tout
à fait et tout à coup l'envi de travail
en professionnel alors puisque le
système marche pourquoi ne pas avoir des
rabatteurs et il aura des rabatteurs un
certain fourier posticheurs de la rue
des mathurins une certaine eriane cas en
une semaine de 48 ans infirmière et un
certain pintard dit francine et ancien
chanteur de caf causses et maquilleurs
de cinéma est là où ils sont là où il
travaille quand il rencontre des gens et
bien ils disent vous savez nous
connaissons et filières et c'est ainsi
qu'on amènera des gens
à pétion il y aura par exemple une
famille cne l'ère des allemands
l'origine des juifs
le mari la femme et le petit garçon rené
qui a 8 ans ils partiront au devant du
docteur petiot qui s'appelle pour cet
acte de résistance docteur eugène on les
reverra jamais et puis il y aura la
famille wolf trois personnes a mené tout
ce que vous avez plus précieux ça c'est
le grand le grand argument de petits os
du dr aux gènes qui dit moi je conseille
les ceintures vous réalisez en diamant
en bijoux et vous mettez ça dans une
ceinture parce personne ne s'apercevra
le rien la famille wolf tout entière
disparaît on ne reverra jamais et puis
c'est la famille bâche six personnes il
passe deux par deux il apporte tout ce
qu'ils ont de plus précieux le reverra
jamais et puis toujours par les
rabatteurs
c'est un mauvais garçon georges réocreux
dijeaux le boxeur ou monsieur jean il
vient trouver petit aux demandes à
passer petit hall et dit surtout réalisé
bien sûr et moi je veux passer avec mon
ami françois albertini dit françois le
corse
et puis je veux pas secs mais trois
femmes parce que je ferai quand je serai
en amérique du sud
j'aurai besoin de travailler alors on
s'arrange jo le boxeur passera une
première fois avec deux femmes et
françois le corse passera une seconde
fois avec une femme on sait que réocreux
apporté 1 million 400 mille francs en
valeur 1 million 400 mille francs de
l'époque
souvenez-vous en 1944 le journal valait
1 franc maintenant ils voient un franc
20 vous pouvez mesurer à peu près la
valeur du franc de cette époque de
l'année
et puis un peu plus tard encore des
mauvais garçons adrien et beste beghi
dit adrien le basque et joseph pires qui
ils viennent avec leurs femmes chacun
dont l'une s'appelle paul est la
chinoise alors eux aussi apporte tout ce
qu'ils ont de plus précieux et même
adrien le basque s'est fait faire des
semelles et des talons en or pour mieux
passer son heure il n'apporte pas
seulement sa fortune celle qu'il a gagné
en travaillant pour la faune cas adrian
basque n'est pas un enfant de choeur il
vient de travailler pendant des années
pour le sinistre la faune de la gestapo
boni lafont s'est emplie des poches
il apporte autre chose et ça c'est
peut-être une révélation que je suis à
même de faire puisque je ne connais
l'anecdote que depuis 48 heures je la
tiens du de l'inspecteur borniche lequel
l'a recueilli des confidences de jo
attia et jo attia lui a dit ceci
savez-vous que pierre loutrel dit
pierrot le fou avait lui aussi gagner
beaucoup d'argent pendant l'occupation
et quand il a appris qu adrien le basque
parti pour l'amérique du sud
il est venu le trouver lui a dit écoute
qu'est ce que tu vas faire là-bas tu
dois faire des affaires alors moi je te
donne mon labo je te rejoindre est plus
tard voilà là de sorte que adrien le
basque est parti non seulement avec son
argent mais avec celui de pierrot le fou
et on ne les a jamais croisés alors
évidemment d une filière qui fonctionne
comme ça ça fait un peu de bruit
d'autant plus que tous ces mauvais
garçons plus ou moins alliés aux
allemands plutôt plus que moins
la police allemande fini par en entendre
parler et on se demande comment on
pourrait prendre ce docteur eugène dont
on parle sans le connaître on va
utiliser un piège affreux
on va forcer un infortuné israélite que
l'on aura tiré d'un camp où il est en
partance pour les camps de la mort on va
le forcer de conduire la police
allemande au dr jay lui n'a fait tout
cela creuse avec le désir le dessin de
rouler bien sûr les allemands et quand
il est près du docteur eugène sachant
qu'il a derrière c'est pas la police
allemande il dit tout de suite à petit
au attention nous sommes suivis et
aussitôt posture qui n'est pas tombé de
la dernière pluie entraîne son compagnon
ils disparaissent dans les bosquets des
champs elysées il fait une nuit noire
souvenez vous aussi vous avez vécu à
cette époque là mais pas une lumière
dans paris la police allemande ne les
retrouve pas mais le malheureux
israélite lui croire à lui aussi que
peux tu peux le faire passer en
l'amérique du sud et on le reverra
jamais cet homme alors la police va
quand même envoyé chez fourier et chez
francine et d'autres agents on arrêtera
francine et et fourrière qui dénonceront
aussitôt le docteur petiot le courage
n'est pas en général le lot des
rabatteurs dr ptito sera arrêté et
interrogé par les allemands comme ils
savent le faire c'est à dire qu'il aura
le droit tout il aura le noir à la
baignoire il aura le droit ou décharge
électrique
on lui livre aller dans 3 mm supplice
affreux et on lui serrera le crâne danse
incertaine en acier il tracera le sang
et quand on le jettera le soir après la
torture dans sa cellule au milieu de
vrais résistants et bien il fera
l'admiration de ses vrais résistants par
son courage par son patriotisme par les
mots d'espoir qu'ils ne cessent de
prononcer et plus tard ces résistants
viendront à son procès et diront c'était
un patriote nous levions
alors voilà encore l'une des énigmes ce
personnage de petit os alors évidemment
on voudrait qu'ils dénoncent la filière
c'est très difficile qu'il dénonce la
filière et nous nous ne savons bien n'a
pas alors il n'y a pas tellement mal
finalement ne pas parler à la fin il as
ses bourreaux et comme les allemands ne
mont-dieu aime bien se remplir les
poches qu'il trafique facilement et bien
le commissaire yacht kun déclare que
s'il touche lui
cent mille francs délibérera peu toile
ont lieu vers 100 mille francs et libère
petit alors il sera se reposer 1 à
auxerre
et quand il rentre nous sommes là en 44
dont il rentre sa femme qui ouvre le
courrier du dior voilà quelque chose
bien embêtant et quoi dont les allemands
réquisitionne la rue lesueur quoi oui
notre hôtel particulier de la rue
lesueur tu dois le donné le 15 mars et
on est au début du mois
c'est alors que vont commencer les
grands feux receveur et oui parce que
depuis le début de l'année 44 depuis le
début de l'année 44 on a pu retrouver
dans la scène de nombreux débris humains
on a trouvé des cadavres
ces cadavres la peau on avait
curieusement été ôtés pour qu'on ne
puisse plus lire l'identité de ces
cadavres puis on a trouvé des troncs
sont des des gens les bras
et même un paquet bien ficelé est un
jour tombé d'un pont dans la seine
malheureusement juste dupont surgissent
et une péniche le pack est tombé sur la
péniche le patron la péniche a ouvert
s'était plaint de débris humains tout ça
aboutisse et sur le sur le bureau si
j'ose dire sur la table deux autopsies
du docteur paul le fameux médecin
légiste et celui-ci était très surpris
parce que chaque fois qu'il y avait une
jambe ou une cuisse il y avait une
entaille dans cette crise il savait bien
pourquoi c'est que lui quand il faisait
le top-6 d'un cadavre qu'ils avaient un
scalpel quand il avait plus besoin son
scalpel mais ne posaient pas sur la
table il le d'un coût net l'enfoncer
dans la cuisse était un tic alors il se
disait c'est un professionnel qui a qui
a découpé tous et des brumes
mais là d'un seul coup on est au début
mars le 15 mars il faut rendre la rue de
ce tueur alors l' incendie le feu de
cheminée
la suite vous la connaissez le 11 mars
l'homme qui part dans la nuit et le
scandale immense qui éclate le lendemain
la presse tout entière
le commissaire massue qui enquêtent et
les journaux les journaux qui parlent
d'ailleurs ça vient à point nommé les
allemands ne vivent pas des heures
agréables à ce moment là et on en que le
commissaire massue se rend rue le soir
pendant que les enquêteurs s'y rendent
les journaux plutôt que de parler du
débarquement
plutôt que de parler des défaites et
bien les journaux parlent eux la
fermeture
ce qui fait que certains n'y croiront
pas cette affaire petit malgré pourtant
toutes les preuves qu'on leur donne
malgré les photographies malgré les
films on voit aux actualités et pourtant
on ne trouve pas petit on va arrêter à
auxerre le frère de petits os il est
dénoncé par un ami commun qui s'appelle
néons des et qui déclare que maurice
piault a tous eu il est exact que
maurice piault à livrer 400 kilos de
chaux mais il déclare qu'il n'a jamais
su pourquoi
usage on ne sait pas on arrête madame
petiau et on va à courçon là où habite
l'ena et rozenn laukyo à un immeuble
et qu'est ce qu'on trouve on trouve 49
valises 49 valise qui contiennent de
tout essai petit os qui les apportaient
la est alors dans ses valises il ya 90
robe 28 complet d'hommes cinquante sept
paires de chaussettes 12 pantalon 11
veste 104 chemise 61 caleçon 93 chemise
de femmes 18 manteau de formes
différentes 320 mouchoirs 14 d'ailleurs
de dames 120 jupe sans combinaison 26
sacs à main 77 paire de gants c'est ce
pyjama 21 poudrier 16 bâton de rouge à
lèvres 22 brosse à dents une culotte de
pyjamas d'enfants et l'on pense au petit
rené kuhn et l'air et sa marraine
reconnaîtra la culotte de pyjama et dira
oui c'est moi qui l'ait mis dans la
valise est petit on ne sait pas où on ne
trouve pas il s'est perdu dans la nature
eh bien nous savons nous ce qu'il a fait
en fait il s'est caché chez un peintre
en bâtiment
il appelle redouté et qui a crû de très
bonne foi abriter un patriote parce que
petit au lieu dit mais oui c'est vrai
les cadavres c'est vrai mais c'était
tous des allemands et des collaborateurs
et alors redouté s'est dit c'est une
honte poursuit c'est un plat il faut le
cacher des allemands est alors la
libération petit os est sur les
barricades peut tuer par tout petit au
s'engage dans les ffi petit os engageant
les milices patriotiques tuyaux prend sa
carte au parti communiste et il s'est
emparé des papiers d'un médecin déportés
qui s'appelle le docteur vétérans valdes
et c'est sous cette identité
il s'est laissé pousser la barbe il est
méconnaissable
et c'est sous cette identité que
il va s'engager dans le 1er régiment de
marche de bari être nommé lieutenant
puis capitaine et puis commissaire
auxiliaires de justice il va siéger à la
caserne de reuil et oui petit le docteur
petiot warrants pendant des semaines la
justice interrogé des collaborateurs ou
présumés tels la justice administré par
petit et vous dirais que nous n'avons
pas vécu une époque étonnant à landon et
puis un jour paraît un article dans un
journal qui s'appelle résistance le sam
après la libération bien sûr un article
qui dit petit aux soldats du reich et
alors là c'est un roman feuilleton
incroyable on raconte que peugeot a fait
des sales coups à marseille qu'il s'est
engagé au ppf de jacques doriot à
marseille n'y a jamais mis les pieds à
marseille mais ça ne fait rien et puis
que même il a dirigé une brigade anti
terroristes dans les maquis et qu'il
avait fait arrêter beaucoup de
maquisards ça fait beaucoup de laisser à
l'époque s'est agacé dans le temps mais
c'est faux ça pourrait rester simplement
un roman comme il y en a malheureusement
un certain nombre quelques fois dans la
presse
non parce que le journal reçoit une
lettre une lettre manuscrite et c'est
petit haut qu'il a adressé peu tous qui
n'est pas grand temps qu'on dise qu'ils
les soldats lui rage et petit haut qui
écrit en rédacteur en chef qui se
réclament de son droit de réponse et qui
dit il faut absolument publié mal être
et qui dit pas du tout j'étais dans la
résistance depuis le premier jour et je
le prouverai et je suis encore
aujourd'hui dans la résistance active à
paris et d'un seul coup voilà qui ouvre
des horizons qu'elle était majeure de
paris recherche tous les médecins qui
servent dans la résistance active et on
se procure une page d'écriture et on
trouve que l'écriture du docteur verma
halde est exactement celle le petit haut
ce qui fait qu'un jour au métro saint
mandé tourelles quatre hommes ceinture
petiau l'art est sans effet de lui le
chef du commando s'appelle simonin c'est
un grand résistant lui aussi mais en
fait on sera plus tard que ce soit
disant résistant était un ancien chef
de police nazie qu'il avait fait mourir
quelques dizaines de résistants et qu'il
en avait fait déporter quelques
centaines de sorte que le faux
résistants petit au voeu d'être est
arrêté par un faux résistants qui
s'appelait simone et vous dirais que
notre époque n'est pas une époque
curieux il est en prison
il retrouve maître florio m florio qui
l'avait défendu lors de son affaire
précédente et mettre un petit os qui
dit-on lors des affaires de drogue vous
avez bien émettre pettiaux qui m florio
qui dit on avait dit à petit en quittant
après cette affaire de drogue
à bientôt ils se retrouvent et petit
haut va exposer à mettre florio son
système de défense
et c'est le même système de défense
qu'il se prépare à exposer devant le
tribunal en attendant l'audience il
écrit il écrit un livre sur le hasard
lui qui est un tel joueur joue encore
une fois en écrivant ce livre qui
s'appelle le hasard vaincu et les cris
des poèmes des poèmes sur les juges sur
les robes noires et on en arrive à la
première audience du procès
du procès passion j'ai assisté à une
audience du procès pétion j'ai vu que tu
arriver et dé poser tranquillement bien
plier son pardessus derrière lui resté
debout regarder le public un public
énorme on se bouscule et le regarder
avec une sorte d'autorité sereine et
puis s'asseoir alors ce procès quelle
défense va-t-il y développer d'abord il
déclare messieurs vous me reprochez 27
assassinat je tiens à vous dire que ça
n'est pas très sérieux
je me réclame mois de 63 alors ne rions
pas voyons les choses enfin alors vous
me dites vous que sont devenus les gens
que vous avez fait prêter reniement
passé eh bien je réponds que sur ce que
vous me reprochez il n'y en a huit
desquels je ne suis pas responsable
madame caïd je ne sais pas qui c'est je
ne sais pas ce qu'il a pu devenir je ne
suis jamais occupé de madame caïd
vendent des verts je ne sais pas non
plus le dr braun berger lui je les fais
passer les quenelles r je les ai fait
passer mais les autres oui tous les
autres je les ai tués j'ai tué les
mauvais garçons et il continue quand la
cour un jour se transporte tout entière
us faire
c'est une sorte d' invasion de cohue
dans le fameux hôtel et lui pérore
explique c'était là qu'il y avait un
charnier
c'était là qu'il y avait eu un autre
c'est là qu'il y avait une faute du
cadavre il avait mis de la chaux il est
l'heure de présider son propre procès et
quand on rentre à l'audience il poursuit
sa défense il dit j'ai tué 63 personnes
c'est vrai mais c'était tous des
allemands est tous des collaborateurs et
quand on lui dit mais enfin et les
malheureuses israélite que vous avez
fait mourir et alors là il a l'audace
suprême de dire mais c'est israélite été
les complices des allemands alors les
témoins qui défie les preuves qui
s'ajoutent les unes aux eaux les
résistants qui viennent dire mais si
c'était un patriote en prison il était
magnifique
les veufs et veuves qui défilent puis
derrière les valises tout ses valises
qui accuse appuyé l'avocat général les
parties civiles ont pas on parle on
parle et la culpabilité
à pareille date en lui même à des éclats
se met en colère
il interpelle l'avocat général monsieur
du pain le tutoie et quand dupas parle
peu tôt lui rétorque en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas prêté serment à pétain qui ne
s'est pas du tout plaisir à l'avocat
général lui et puis c'est la plaidoirie
de maître florian
il plaide 6h et disons que c'est sa plus
grand le plus extraordinaire plaidoirie
qu'on puisse envisager alors que tout
accable son client maître florio va
prendre à sa charge cette défense
difficile et va par un prodige de talent
arrivé à semer le doute dans tout ce
public chez tous ces jurés chez le
président tout le monde on ne sait plus
où sont les traîtres où sont les
résistants ou sont les collaborateurs on
ne sait plus du tout madame brand berger
a reconnu le chapeau de son mari chapeau
htc geslot avant la guerre et qu'elle a
fait réparer chez berthe hey pendant la
guerre et il vient d'ailleurs la marque
de berthet et sa accable petit à petit
on l'a retrouvé le chapeau maîtres
florio dit simplement moi je suis allé
chez jet d'eau celle où j'ai appris que
la maison garder l'empreinte de toutes
les têtes des gens à qui on a fait des
chapeaux j'ai donc trouvé l'empreinte du
dr braun berger la voilà elle ne
s'applique pas à ce chapeau ça n'est pas
le chapeau du dr braun berger par
ailleurs madame brand berger a dit que
pendant l'occupation
elle avait fait réparer le chapeau chez
bertail voici un document qui prouve que
berdai était fermée pendant l'occupation
et tout à coup on se prend à douter on
s'est dit mais alors quoi et quand après
six heures
le fait de m'être florio s'assied la
salle spontanément applaudi
mais c'était impossible qu'ils auraient
pu faire acquitter petit on délibère
pendant deux heures ce qui est très
court pour 27 crime
et quand on revient on a lavé petit odin
d'un décret mais on ne lui reproche plus
que 26 mais ça suffit pour la peine de
mort bien sûr
et comment alors maintenant il attend la
mort en prison on est allé chercher la
guillotine malheureusement la guillotine
a été endommagé deux parentes dans les
monts parlement de paris
alors monsieur des fourneaux le bourreau
v a dû faire venir la guillotine de
province et puis un matin
dans la cellule à 4h45 entre le
directeur de la prison l'avocat général
du pain le juge d'instruction collecti
maîtres florio c'est du pin qui secoue
petit eau qui dort avec une tranquillité
totale
eddy pettiaux soyez courageux c'est leur
petit os qui se réveille et qui dit tu
me fais chier
l'avocat général qui n'a peut-être pas
très bien compris qui dit que tu avais
vous une déclaration à faire je les ai
déjà fait mais je le répète tu me fais
chier
loris yonnaise très tranquille reconnaît
florian comment allez-vous moins chère
mme sahabi s'assied à une table pour
écrire une dernière lettre à sa femme et
à son fils est pile lomagne et arrive le
lab et bergers non papa de curés ou
m'excuserai monsieur l'abbé je ne crois
rien pourtant docteur votre femme que
j'ai vu hier a souhaité vous soyez bénis
ah ah bon alors fait et vite
puis ils partent dans le long couloir
maîtres florio à qui j'ai parlé de
peinture m'a dit ceci m'a dit vous savez
j'ai vu pas mal de gens allaient à la
mort pas mal de condamner gagner lâche
et là aussi qu'ils sont courageux très
courageux mais se courra bas il apparaît
toujours cette rouages parce que il ya
une certaine raideur dans l'attitude
dans la démarche
oui on est courageux mais ça se voit
quand les courages pettiaux il avait
l'air d'aller prendre le métro
tranquillité totale décontraction
absolue un moment simplement il dit à
mon collaborateur dit dans fait
attention à l'avocat général il est si
pas libre à ses duels il va s'évanouir
voilà le bourreau
on lui découpe la chemise quel dommage
ni petit os x il une si jolie chemise et
puis il dit à m florio pour garderai pas
1 m ce sera pas beau on lui demande s'il
a encore une déclaration à faire du nom
sur un voyageur qui emporte ses bagages
à l'instant plus tard le couperet tombe
c'est vrai qu'il a emporté cette bagarre
et c'est vrai que nous ne savons pas que
nous ne saurons jamais
comment il a opéré c'est vrai que nous
ne savons pas qui ne seront jamais quel
était le nombre de ses victimes c'est
vrai que nous ne savons pas ce que nous
ne serons jamais ce qu'il a fait de cet
argent qui l'a recueillie dans tous ses
crimes
una trésor de petits os on a même des
mots l'île l'hôtel de la rue lesueur
avec des pioches pierre par pierre on
n'a rien tombé mais tout ça n'est pas
aussi important que la question qui nous
brûle les lèvres
nous ne savons pas nous ne serons
peut-être jamais lié tu es vraiment
petit
cet homme car ils ne sont neufs le 120
123 1936 a été déclaré en état de
démence d'après l'article 64 du code
pénal il n'y a ni délit ni crime qui
celui qui les a commis là fait en état
de démence
alors
où est la vérité des psychiatres qui se
trompe ou plutôt petit qui les trompent
et qui nous trompent tous encore au delà
de la main ou plutôt accord n'est ce pas
aussi cette société cette époque où ils
vivent et où il a accompli ses crimes
cette société cette époque là qui était
en état de démence
[Musique]